la muerte de George Floyd fue producto
del racismo sistemático un informe
presentado por el fiscal general de
Estados Unidos Mary karland concluyó que
dentro del departamento de policía de la
ciudad de Minneapolis existe un patrón
sobre el uso excesivo de la fuerza
contra la población afrodescendiente y
de comunidades indígenas
descubrimos que el departamento de
policía de Minneapolis utiliza
habitualmente fuerza excesiva a menudo
cuando no es necesaria incluida la
fuerza letal injusta y el uso
irrazonable de armas teiser los agentes
del departamento disparaban armas de
fuego a las personas sin evaluar si
representaba alguna amenaza y mucho
menos una amenaza que justificaría la
fuerza letal
la investigación inició en 2021 y fue
encabezada por el Departamento de
Justicia estadounidense en ella se
revela que dereckhaobin oficial que
asesinó a George Floyd después de
arrodillarse en su cuello por más de 9
minutos ya había presentado un
comportamiento abusivo en el pasado Pero
el departamento policial no hizo nada el
jefe de la policía de la ciudad afirma
que reconocen sus errores y que están
trabajando para enmendarlos
estoy aquí hoy en nombre de la policía
de Minneapolis para firmar nuestro
compromiso de avanzar juntos es nuestro
momento de liderar sanar reconstruir y
crear el tipo de departamento de policía
que todos los residentes de Minneapolis
perecen
el asesinato de George Floyd en mayo de
2020 detonó una serie de protestas de la
comunidad afroamericana en Minneapolis
denunciando la brutalidad policial de la
que han sido objeto históricamente y que
hoy fue confirmada en el informe